this is a production of Cornell
University
have you seen any local effects of
extreme weather and climate change in
the years especially that especially
because you your native you to Dutchess
County ah yes i have it seems like the
winners are getting much milder we're
getting more so i think more severe
weather as we head south seems the
beginning more snow more cold winners
are not nearly as bad we've had three
major weather events in the last couple
of years 12 years ago the excessive snow
throughout the winter last fall with the
you know being hit by tremendous amounts
of rain hurricane and then this winter
with I don't ever recall winner of this
as easy as it was I've gone through
snowless winters but never with this
mile as it's been we didn't have the
link to actually and we didn't have a
winner and I say a lot less hey was fed
a lot less hey was used which is you
know don't allege sort it's good for
those that didn't have to buy had it but
it's poor for those of us that solve I
hurts it's an issue what the insect
population and the bad bugs that weren't
killed in today's paper was a major
thing about you know Lyme disease beings
you know perhaps the banner year for
Lyme disease so I'm really concerned
over what's coming down the road
though i can predict i can only hope
thanks won't be his tires maybe what
happened to your farm during the extreme
weather events and how much money you
think you lost how did it affect you ah
curse is started in April last year with
the fact that we had so much trouble
getting the crops in just you know we
got them seated we couldn't go and go
back and roll them roll them pick up
rock which in turn we probably got a
poor or catch a seed than we should have
so that that bothered us you know just
little little things that you know don't
always add up the fact that you have to
send people again and again back to the
field because there's big wet spot she
and go around and stuff like that takes
a lot more time we lost probably half
our old crop because we couldn't get it
we couldn't harvest it in the window
that we had it went down we lost a lot
of it the biggest thing that's bothering
me right today is that we left probably
fifteen thousand dollars worth of hay
second cutting grass hay in the field
that we could not harvest last fall we
made many attempts we got summin but we
knew a lot of hay so we we left $15,000
with a hey of the field which is really
financially bothering me right now
strapping me we lost the field of corn
that was you know a lot of it was
management fault for not chopping that
field we left it for grain thought we
could get it and we got the late snow
storm and it was very talk learning it
took him down so we lost we lost a lot
of corn over there so we probably lost a
minimum of forty thousand or so
crops you can as a farm you can you can
weather the storm but you can't weather
continued with storms you can you can
take it on the chin you can you know you
come back spring brings eternal hope and
that's as a farmer that's what's that's
what fuels me that's what you know as I
as I become alive I mean this for you
know it as the warm weather comes you we
all feel like doing or as the farmer
it's just so much easier if you know we
think again this year I have this
problem x cubed vision that this is
going to be the best year
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu